because if you sent me to a place where
there's a bunch of flammables and
bottles
i as a cop pick them up and i turn them
in as evidence
so i should be able to validate those
stories and i think as we
do that we will have better information
for you
that confirms or denies uh the social
media posts that we've been working
through
um do you still believe that the
unmarked cars and the flammables is some
aspect of this people are seeing a lot
of
or unlicensed plated cars i have at
least two
confirmed reports from local law
enforcement
of cars no license plates
so i have those two clear episodes
uh hitman county and bloomington both
have given me
actual reports that i could get my hands
on that make some sense about that
uh some of the others i'm still working
through trying to get reports and get
factual data to back it up
one thing you do have factual data on
now is with a number of arrests made are
you still
finding that the majority of the people
you're arresting and putting in jail
for curfew or whatever are from
minnesota
with a with a minority of them being
from elsewhere
that is that would be accurate yes
today is june 1st and a lot of hair
salons and bars
are loud open across the state many
though in minneapolis and st
paul are either finding it impossible to
open because of what's going on or
they don't feel it's right to open what
can you tell them
what kind of help must be underway for
them that are now being doubled down on
yeah that's the thing and i think the
conversation i heard somebody talk about
this the conversation around uh
the unfinished work of the the
legislature that'll
convene more than likely here by june
12th that's going to be critically
important to talk about that type of
thing i think the one thing is with
business owners that now have this
ability
as it's been throughout the whole cove
at 19 it doesn't mean you have to open
it means you adjust and what we knew all
along is i think again
i i i'm not going to encourage someone
to go into an unsafe situation but we're
going to try and provide as law
enforcement always does
a safe civic environment that if it
makes sense for you to open your
restaurant or have your salon we want we
want that happening but
i would say need to be thoughtful i
think it's probably again i'll let the
mayor say this
um watching locally what the situation
with minneapolis saint paul because i
think what you'd see is in
in greater minnesota i'm guessing most
of them will open
and try and do what they need to do so
mayor if you want to comment on
we knew starting with covet 19 that we
were going to need to
help businesses recover in some form
from a fiscal standpoint after the
economy began to reopen
now in addition to providing help from a
fiscal standpoint we've got entire
corridors in minneapolis where buildings
have been destroyed
we need to have help to replace those
buildings to get people back on track
and
i know the governor and mayor are
committed to to helping to provide that
necessary support
i mean it's it's important to remember
that these are these are communities
that have in some parts been burned
both fiscally as well as the buildings
themselves
these are barber shops these are grocery
stores these are mom and pop shops that
are going to need substantial assistance
as we get back and i can say that you
know we are committed to it
last question because i'm unclear
if just the support people are being
pulled or
will there be national guard troops on
the ground in the twin cities tonight
and if
you can tell me how many and be specific
because the national gardens got a got a
lot of attention and i think a lot of
people are very grateful for them
no thank you very much to to allow me to
be very specific about this
on saturday and sunday
i would say the assessment of uh
the the tactics employed by the
by the mac by the state patrol by the
two police departments were very
effective
we were part of that we were small part
of that we were part of that team
okay that level of effort
i have guaranteed to the governor for an
unspecified amount of time he knows what
it is i've laid it out for him i'm not
going to lay it out here
but what we had on the ground last night
will be in minneapolis and st
paul guaranteed that is what i told the
governor
as we begin peeling pieces off of this
that presence will remain through that
time that i've given the governor
but the violence didn't continue to
accelerate
at a very rapid rate so what we did is
we created capacity that we didn't
necessarily need
because we started started on
stabilizing
the security environment in minneapolis
and st paul
so i don't think any citizen of
minnesota
wants thousands of guardsmen to be
sitting in their armory
away from their homes away from their
families away from their employers
just waiting for what we believe and
what we hope
is a downturn on violence why why did we
why did we lower the curfew
today it wasn't because violence
increased that's not why we lowered
the curfew right we lowered it because
our citizens
responded to us our citizens responded
to the pleas of the law enforcement
and our and our elected officials over
here
i i think would be wasteful if we just
left these men and women
sitting somewhere hoping that it gets
worse so we can use them that's that's
not that that's not fair to them
it's not prudent and and it's not the
advice i gave to the governor and he
he agreed to that so thank you and i
would just thank you general and i would
just say uh
we are not going to live in fear we're
going to live with the future being
possibilities
we don't fear the future we create it
here we know we've got work to do
we will not leave citizens unprotected
now this is where we gather back out
this is where folks make some choices
um i will say this i think we need to
watch very carefully around the covet 19
issue but i think we need to make
movements we're seeing some good flat
numbers i know jan will
uh malcolm will talk about that um but
this is our opportunity so we got work
to do
we'll come back keep updates today and
uh grateful thank you
what about the uh is there gonna be a
curfew tonight what about metro transit
and the interstates
that information will come out sooner as
well as the the freeway situation
so they're clarifying that thank you
thank you
yeah we're getting a ton of questions
about transition
cnn
we can move back to where you'd like
here we are live on the air at the
moment
and scattering the protesters at that
point for people to
clear the area and so we walked away
[Music]
why am i under arrest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh